- Our next guest, fun fact
has been smooched by none
other than Harry Styles.
Maybe we could all
vicariously jump in his body
and be him for a minute.
All right.
Please welcome the incredible, talented,
just, oh, he's so everything.
I don't know where to begin.
It's Nick Kroll.
(audience cheering)
It's hard to describe you.
I'm like, oh my God.
I'm so happy for your life.
- Thank you.
- I mean, how is being a dad?
I mean, what's-
- It's such a bummer.
No.
(audience laughs)
Has anyone ever come on
the show and done that?
- By the way-
- I regret it, Drew.
Every day I regret it.
No, but it's been,
it has been amazing.
It's like a true,
like, true gift.
We have a very,
he's a really beautiful, good boy.
And at this moment I'm like,
oh, this is the best thing I've ever done.
And I feel so excited to be a father.
(audience claps)
- [Drew] And do you,
are you a ham with your kids?
'Cause I am such a ham with my kids.
- For sure,
and I do Jon Hamm for
the kids all the time.
(audience laughs)
No, but I definitely,
I mean, I'm desperate for his approval,
and I do the voices for him,
and I'll do a voice,
and I'll sort of, I'll be trying to-
- Like what voice?
Could you give us the voice?
- I'll do like-
- Not to put you on the spot.
- No, no, I'll do like,
I'll give him an Elmo or you know,
and he doesn't even know who Elmo is.
But I'll just be talking to him
and I'll be like,
"Hey, how are you doing?"
And, and he'll-
(audience applauds)
- Oh my God, can you imagine
what it's like to be Nick Kroll's kid?
- And he'll, he literally will be like,
and as soon as I do a voice like that,
he goes, "Hi."
(audience laughs)
Like, he thinks, he's like,
someone else has walked into the room.
- Which is comedy in itself.
He's your straight man.
- Thank you.
Yeah, that's what I tell him every day.
(Drew laughs)
But he's, no, it's really,
there's no joy like hearing
the laughter of your child.
It really is like, a truly...
(audience applauding)
- Now I was reading about your wife Lily.
- Yes.
- And you guys met on a dating app?
- [Nick] Yes.
- [Drew] Okay, this is so hopeful.
- [Nick] It is. She's-
- [Drew] Oh, she's so beautiful.
- She's beautiful.
She's a landscape designer
and a botanical installation artist.
- That's so sexy.
- Yeah, she does like, truly amazing work.
And we met because, as you know,
it's like, when you come,
when you're, when you have been
in an industry for a
certain amount of time,
you end up feeling like
you've met everyone,
and your world becomes
smaller and smaller.
And I got on this app
to sort of try to meet people
that were outside of
my particular circles,
and I ended up meeting Lily
and we, I think she messaged me
on like New Year's Eve.
Like, I don't know, 2018.
And then we chatted for a while
and then finally met months later.
And here we are.
And then we, now we have,
we're married and have a child.
And so, it's beautiful.
It's really great. Yeah.
(audience applauds)
- Now, Nick has got this
brilliant new standup special.
It is hilarious and incredibly personal.
We have a clip. Take a look.
- I am wearing silk boxer shorts
like a businessman on
vacation in Hong Kong.
(audience laughs)
Those slide right on down.
Lizzy looks over at me
and she is now eye to eye
with my bald little cashew.
(audience laughs)
She is horrified.
Jenny, the girl who pantsed me,
is mortified,
and I am now a comedian.
(audience claps)
- What was it about this special that,
did you have a north star
of what you wanted this to be?
- This particular project,
I hadn't done a standup special
in like, over a decade
and I, you know,
I had done a lot more like voices
and character stuff
and I really wanted to
do a standup special
that felt much more personal.
It was actually Lily, my wife,
when she was my girlfriend, she was like,
"Why don't you do an hour,
why don't you go do a special?"
And I was like, "Ah, that's for the other,
that's for all my friends
who are like, they're standups."
And then I sort of was
like, you know what?
I'm gonna do it.
And I took a note from
what we had been doing
on "Big Mouth," which is this
animated show that I make
which is very personal
and largely autobiographical
and much more vulnerable than
anything I'd ever done before.
And so, I tried to take that
to my standup special
and sort of really talk
about where I am in my life.
And then, so many things
in my life unfolded
while I was making it.
Like, the lockdown
and getting married and having a child
and all of that
sort of informed the standup.
And so that hour's a much more piece of,
I hope first and foremost, funny,
but also very kind of honest
for where I am in my life.
(Drew sighs)
It's really great, yeah.
(audience applauds)
- We have to go to a
quick commercial break.
Will you take us to break
as any character you would ever wanna do?
I just love hearing you do your voices.
- Okay, I'll, I could do
maybe Gunter from "Sing."
(Drew yelps)
- Sorry. Okay.
- Don't go anywhere.
We're heading back in time
to relive a little bit
of the seventh grade,
and so, stick around.
(upbeat percussive music)